-Welcome.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
We are coming at you
from Studio 6A
here in Rockefeller Plaza
in New York City.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, we are just one week
away from Election Day!
[ Applause ]
I can't believe it's that soon.
I mean, it feels like
the last four years
have just really flown by!
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, every morning
since 2016,
Democrats have been carving
the days into the walls
like they're doing time
at Rikers Island.
[ Laughter ]
If Biden wins, Democrats are
gonna walk out of their houses
with an extra 50 pounds
of muscle
and a jug of toilet wine.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, we're just seven
days away from the election,
and just seven months
from knowing who won.
That's exciting.
[ Audience groans ]
Yep. In seven days
we'll find out if Trump's
sticking around or getting
replaced like the Bachelorette.
This week cannot go fast enough.
If you're looking for ways
to pass the time,
just ask Joe Biden to tell
one story from high school.
"My pal Skee-Ball and I
were on our way
to the sock hop, and..."
[ Laughter ]
But seven days is still
a lot of time.
If you get in line to vote now,
there's a really good chance
you'll make it to the front
by November 3rd.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's excited about
this election.
I mean, check out how many
people have already voted.
-We are one week out
from Election Day,
and look at that number.
More than 65 million ballots
already cast.
-That's right, over 65 million
have already voted.
And thanks to the Supreme Court,
almost 3 million of those
will be counted.
[ Laughter ]
These voting numbers
are incredible.
The United States could have
its highest election turnout
since 1908.
You know 2020's been rough when
we're like,
"Let's party like it's 1908!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Drumming march plays ]
Wow, I love that.
1908 was a lot like 2020.
The country was divided,
turnout was high,
and Bernie Sanders
lost in the primary.
[ Audience groans ]
A lot of groaners tonight, huh?
[ Laughter ]
Cheer up.
Come on, man.
That's right, the U.S. is on
track for the highest election
turnout since 1908.
That got me wondering, why were
so many people voting in 1908?
Well, when you compare today's
issues to back then,
it kind of makes sense.
For example, in 2020,
voters want to stop
a global warming
catastrophe.
In 1908, voters wanted
to stop pollution
from the four cars that existed.
In 2020, voters want to settle
things at the ballot box.
In 1908, voters wanted
to settle things
by racing a donkey
and an elephant.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in 2020,
voters complain
the election season
is like watching paint dry.
In 1908, voters said,
"Paint drying?
I got to check this out."
[ Laughter ]
With the time running short
until the election,
both campaigns are going all out
and holding as many rallies
across the country as they can.
Listen to this.
-An active day on the trail,
Joe Biden stopping in Georgia,
Kamala Harris in Nevada.
The former President,
Barack Obama,
campaigning for the
Democrats in Orlando, Florida.
Jill Biden heads to Maine.
The President hits a trio
of Midwest states --
Michigan, Wisconsin,
and Nebraska's Second
Congressional District.
Vice President Mike Pence is
in the Carolinas today,
and the First Lady is
traveling to Pennsylvania.
-Whew. Usually the only people
who travel this much
are salesmen and fugitives.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump and Pence
are everywhere.
Even the coronavirus was like,
"Guys, please, gimme a second
to catch up."
I think all the traveling
confused Trump,
'cause he bragged about saving
Nebraska's auto industry
and rescuing the great
dairy farms of Michigan.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure Trump's rallies are
really moving the needle.
It's hard to convince voters
you deserve a second term
when your speech has 42 mentions
of the word "plague."
[ Laughter ]
But you can tell Trump's getting
tired 'cause at one rally
he just rolled out a television
and played a video
like a substitute teacher.
[ Laughter ]
"You know what's better than
reading 'Moby Dick'?
Watching 'Air Bud.'"
[ Laughter ]
Listen to what's going on
with gym's in Newark.
-New restrictions aimed
at stopping a surge
in coronavirus cases
take effect today in Newark.
Gyms and fitness centers are
under orders to shut down
for 30 minutes every hour
for a deep cleaning.
-30 minutes every hour?
The only person who's going to
get in shape is the janitor.
[ Laughter ]
Already there's one creepy
employee who just walks up
to the machines and whispers,
"Bath time."
[ Laughter ]
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
♪ Bath time ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
Go, rap.
-♪ Bath time, bath time ♪
♪ It's time to take a bath ♪
♪ It's time to get
some soap out ♪
♪ And then you wash your -- ♪
[ Laughter ]
-I was waiting for you
to cut me off.
Say, hey, hey!
-Whoa, whoa, whoa,
this is a family show.
Sorry. Sorry,
I forgot to do that. Yeah.
♪♪
[ Vocalizing ]
-Wait.
That's Billy Bob Thornton's
character on --
-Oh yeah, "Sling Blade."
-[ Mumbling ]
You --
-Bath time, mm-hmm.
-Mm-hmm, bath time.
"You mind if I hang out
with your son
and be best friends with him?"
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if you guys should
be hanging out in the woods.
No, I'm doing like --
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
♪ Call me Mr. Bombastic ♪
♪ Mr. Fantastic ♪
[ Scatting ]
♪ Mr. Ro... ♪
♪ Bath time, duh-nuh-nuh-nuh,
bath time ♪
-It's not right.
-♪ Ro... ♪
-It's not right
without Higgins here.
-♪ Bath time ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Now you got to
wash your -- time ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
-It's not right.
-It's not right, no.
Oh yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Hey, I'm a little worried that
Newark Planet Fitness
is taking better precautions
than the coronavirus task force.
[ Laughter ]
Let's change gears.
I heard about a billionaire
in California
who is feuding with
his neighbor.
And recently, their fight
took an interesting turn.
Watch this.
-♪ Sit right back and
you'll hear a tale ♪
♪ A tale of a fateful trip ♪
-Two neighbors in Laguna Beach,
California, they've been
in a dispute over
a lawn sculpture.
So, billionaire Bill Gross,
he's been blaring
the "Gilligan's Island"
theme song at all hours
of the day and night in an
attempt to annoy the neighbors
in hopes that they'll drop their
complaint over the sculpture.
[ Laughter ]
-So to recap, he annoyed
his neighbor by also
making himself listen to the
"Gilligan's Island" theme song.
[ Laughter ]
He was like, "Sorry, I only
wanted to do it for three hours,
but it wound up being much
longer."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
[ Applause ]
[ Ding! ]
Bob Denver fans.
♪♪
♪ I'm Bob Denver ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Bob Denver ♪
I'll be honest,
I just think it's nice
that we can still find
things to fight about
besides the election.
And finally I saw that Four Loko
is coming out with
new bottled drinks called
Pregame.
Here they are.
-What?
-It's perfect for when you want
to pass out before
leaving the house.
[ Laughter ]
To buy a bottle, you have
to show your ID
and give an emergency contact.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. You can either
drink it or just skip a step
and put yourself
in the back of a police car.